pat on a scale of one to ten
how scared is bezos right now i say he's
out of 40.
i bet he is you think so i bet he's
freaking out this sounded good
you know a while ago when he was talking
to laura and his girl about doing it and
impressing her but now that he's
buckling in come on man
this space cowboy nerd is freaking out i
guarantee you
his ex-wife's thinking i just should
have held on a little longer
why did i settle for half i could have
got it all
people are only interested in this for
the same reason they're interested in
nascar in the special olympics
you seriously think that you seriously
think people are saying they're hoping
something happens
uh yeah i think so man did you see what
tulsi gabbard say well
do us a favor and stay there
oh i love me some tulsi tell us he's
like lose a favor kai can you pull up a
video so we can see it
on twitter okay is this it is this
literally live right now
is that what it looks like yeah that way
are you kidding me yeah
that's it it's very phallic this guy's
taking a dildo into space
open it up open it up open it up
wow blue over here so it's gonna go
straight up
is there an audio or no it's real for
basils right now oh my god
do you guys remember the end of austin
powers one when
it goes to the outer space this takes
guts to get into that
johnson
[Music]
that's an amazing view
[Music]
how many flat earthers are tweeting
right now that this is staged
okay so this is gonna last definitely
watching this look at he he even put the
testes on there what's going on bezos
so they're gonna burn all the fuel and
then that's when it starts coming down
it's gonna go 62 miles up yeah what do
you mean it's going to always feel it
starts coming down
that's the way it goes bro 460.
it's a cool sight you think he's worried
gerard do you think he's worried i don't
know he's he's got a
he's inside of a building that's
strapped to a nuclear bomb that's going
a thousand miles an hour if you're not
worried you're probably not human you
actually think he's worried
i think so i mean this is unchartered
territory i mean
you can't prepare for this all the way
so i think a little bit
i think there's a reason why he brought
people he loves the most who
who's in there with him let me just read
who's in there with them let me uh
all right bezos page four this is
actually happening the richest man in
the world is out there
he's in that capsule right there do you
think the outside is ribbed for her
pleasure or
now gerard you either need to find
a girl you need some help buddy
somebody we thought it was adam
gerard's got adam beat right now adam if
you're watching this
buddy rockets for your entire life have
looked like that just so you know that
it's your mind that's screwed up right
now that all you see is a dildo
that's just a rocket i can't think of
one rocket i've ever seen in my life
with a mushroom tip
now it's jeff bezos turn to make history
with flight into space this is nbc news
story
just over a week uh after richard
branson flew to the edge of space
fellow billionaire jeff bezos is set for
similarly high stakes trip abroad his
own rocket but online keep it up kai
keep it up unlike
virgin galactic unity space the new
shepherd rocket and capsule fly
autonomous autonomously without pilots
on board so there's no pilots on board
no no so they've just hit their max
speed it's leveling off that's three
times the speed of sound
this is where the guy jumped out is this
like the same height where that guy
jumped well they're 200 000 212 look at
that they're up there man
beautiful day
unreal okay slowing down what is the
practical
all jokes decide what is the practical
act you know
what why are they going through this
billion dollar space race they don't
they don't they don't tax in space so
it's like you can't go
live there 481 days you know you're
saving so much money
are they going to look to mine on the
moon are they resources
they're going to charge 200 grand a
flight for these things going forward
200 g by the way did you know that the
guy that paid 28 million to go up with
these guys yeah backed out
he didn't go they had to go they had to
go to plan b there to bring the 18 year
old kid that was on the next one why not
i'm sure he pulled an ashton kutcher and
his wife told him you're not going
that's what happened with kutcher what
happened with that ashton kutcher
already paid for
the next mission with branson already
paid for it a couple hundred grand
and mila said you're not going and so
he's not so i said dude where's your man
card i mean come
on he's handing it surely mila said
you're not going and he's not going
they had a conversation she didn't feel
comfortable with it so he backed out
he's not doing it if you got to lose
your man card to anybody mila kunis
isn't the
person i'm losing best mila kunis movie
uh best mila kunis movie has to be
forgetting sorry i mean i don't think
you're saying anything
please time out friends with benefits
with justin timberlake better than
forgetting sarah marshall
principal benefits is good but it's not
and it's not sarah marshall let me tell
you sarah marshall is is
maybe it's got to go into the
smithsonian it's one of those unique
movies
inside of you yeah i'd say it's saying
no one mentioned black swan
it was a good movie too did you see that
one yeah yeah so let's see here several
other milestones may be set on this trip
joining bases will be one passenger who
stands to become the oldest person to
reach space and another person who's
the youngest wally frank 82 is a former
test pilot who was one
of the mercury 13 women who underwent
training
in 1960s to demonstrate that women could
meet nasa standards for its astronaut
corpse
at 18 the dutch teenager oliver damon
could become the youngest astronaut
rounding out the four-person crew is
jeff bezos's brother
mark that's right he's going up with his
brawl you know i think the scariest
point for bezos is when that parachute
opens and you're dropping then that's a
that's a long way to come down
so are they going to be right now or no
they're going to release the video from
inside after the fight
some of them spinning around is going to
come later so right now all you hear is
them talking
that's awesome he doesn't sound nervous
dog no he doesn't man
he doesn't he's he's got 200 000 tickets
to sell now
this is great he's gone straight into
sales let me ask you a question if
you're watching this
if you're watching this and if you could
afford it thumbs up two hundred thousand
dollars you'd spend to go there
thumbs down i could care less about
going up there smash
thumbs up if you would spend if you had
the money 200 000 wasn't anything to you
can you lower my audio by like 10 if if
money wasn't an issue to you
would you spend 200 000 to go to space
thumbs up thumbs down i could care less
about going to space
what's yours thumbs down i i don't like
heights number one okay and and i don't
need thrills i
i just don't need them out of life i
don't need them i i get thrills other
ways i don't need to manufacture them by
going up into space i'm not into it
thousand dollars i'd spend two hundred
thousand dollars to be weightless
i think yeah
how much could gerard bench in space
five
million pounds unlimited he could lift
that rocket
would you want to do that would you want
to ah dude yeah i'm an adrenaline junkie
for sure so you would yeah i i think so
kai yeah what's your what david i want
you to think about madeline i want you
to think about kai would you go 200
000 money is not an issue i would you
would i wouldn't be one of the first
people to do it but like
i'd be maybe like 10 rounds in
i'd be you would do it yeah you could
care less not only i could care like i
hate roller coasters
they freak me out i don't think i can
make it i just don't like the
you'd be the guy turning around coming
back oh you're damn right i'd be raising
my hand
is it is it the rules escort me down
this i think the audio is
very loud all in all so lower it 10
total it's a little too loud
if you ask me even for us okay is it the
roller coaster that freaks you out tom
or is it
the the meth head running the roller
coaster see i i think
i i got a little more uh
if it's just commercialized and it's
like a flight let's do it but if it's
like this crazy
tight spaceship i'll sit this one out
how funny would that be though and like
if this was so old hat in 50 years that
they just have like old carnies running
running the rockets in the space yeah
there's like one guy with a with a
marble red hanging out the side of his
mouth like hey you ready to go up to
mars but
would you would you do it or no uh yeah
i would also have to wait for a couple
runs
but i i mean i like roller coasters and
adrenaline but
that's risking your whole life yeah i
agree
you're going you get motorcycles i would
i would i mean to me it's
but i will tell you i don't like tight
spaces i'm not a fan of tight spaces but
i would go so
okay so landed back uh that's insane
then it came right back on that landing
spot isn't it
it looks kind of burnt fully it needs a
car wash that's so it's coming back down
man that's it yep well now they're on
their way down i think they got like
three minutes where they get to do
cartwheels and stuff
you know so we can get this in in clear
6k
hd but every freaking ufo video that we
see
is like a dot matrix from from an old
school like game boy like come on
it's a hell of a steady cam they have
yeah
i mean look there you go if you would
have said years ago one day there's
going to come a time where you can go to
space for 200 grand or pop
i actually think this is going to be a
business model and i think
then the next thing is who can can you
lower the audio at this point
i think the next thing is how creative
they get with this
meaning what else is going to happen you
know now it's a publicity stunt now it's
going to be like who's going to be in it
what celebrity
are they going to be able to pull a
kardashian a rock a
ronaldo a messy somebody that's going to
want to go like you got to market this
thing for people to say i want to go do
it
is a youtuber going to go on there make
a video about it and get like
you know 200 million views and oh my
gosh you got to do it like at a
discounted rate
what's going to be next here's what's
going to be the next thing
join the 30-mile high club and you call
up there
you see that could you see some point
you just fired gerard up right now
now it makes sense now you're in it for
sure
it's paid by the hour i like it yeah
folks we were able to get so by the way
just so you know most people
want to go everybody wants to go i mean
it's a nine to one yeah i know who wants
to go and who doesn't want to go
nine to one who says i'm willing to go
versus those who don't want to go 200
000 actually seems like not a lot of
money so you're telling me eight people
that's
eight hundred thousand for for eight
people times eight people no no four
four times 200 000
yeah for rocket launch i can't believe
it it's got to be that's got to
be more expensive to send that thing up
i don't know maybe they're going to be
bigger when they go up maybe this is the
the test module if my
i think you're allowed more than two
bags or
[Laughter]
american airlines they imagine if they
start doing that you'll you'll take off
maybe you'll go to space when we good
and damn well feel like they had to turn
that flight around because someone
didn't have that mask on
all right let us let us give you a
softball story here here let's give a
story to gerard kai can we
let's let this thing let this thing keep
going in the background we'll see what's
going on here as we get up must said
it's uh
space garbage is supposed to be like
like no all jokes aside like space
garbage is going to be a big industry
because they have so much stuff up there
they have to protect their their
satellites so going up there and
cleaning the the space garbage that's in
orbit is going to be like a big
the stuff he thinks about like who wakes
up in the morning saying i need to start
a waste management company in space
there it is they just landed michael
frenzie's yeah
wouldn't that be funny if a martian got
out like it commandeered the thing
different we come to take over the
planet jeff is probably gonna get out
with his famous smile and his laugh
you know his life right alex jones is
watching this getting angry
patrick yeah earlier don't come from
outer space i told you the hidden wrench
while they've already been here
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]